assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to this controversial
video which we which has been quite
controversial
at least we go out the video we're going
to talk about before we start we want to
please I was upon what I loved the most
noise for the most rust or praises for
ingratitude belong to him for the works
that we do now obviously as you guys
know released a Nasheed video my name is
machine video a lot of people start
getting a panic attack or I should call
it PI T attack basically saying it's not
permissible you know it looks her arm
you know you guys are you taking the
fire of your hand movement
you know Almighty says was his sound he
try and make his voice sound like a
woman that's imitating a woman which is
backbiting chronologies is doing that
just got his voice a certain way and all
these kind of management going on out
you use music blah blah blah blah blah
so basically this we said you know what
let's look into this
yeah let's open this without being
biased because we don't do machines as a
living yeah you just say what like you
could say okay all my issues gonna be
based but us so we looked into the
matter and also to do the video we paid
our own pocket so when I've gained in
anything so moosa' actually looked into
the matter in death cuz I've been quite
busy he's been speaking to a brother in
madina and he's been in contact with him
more in Wadena but yeah he's in Riyadh
yeah Riyadh same thing I just say be
open with you know the skin think anyway
side area so basically he's been in
contact with them to be honest before I
go into a more tantrum because I got a
lot you're at my chest we're gonna let
Musa elaborate on what he found out more
so what did you find out when yeah so
bismillah hamdulillah salat wa salam ala
rasulillah sallallahu sanam my bad
firstly you know the reason for us doing
the video i want to structure the video
a little bit firstly I want to say why
we chose to do the video as I mentioned
we have no benefit in terms of income
from this actually you're really poor
hole in my pocket a little bit but we we
actually paid out of our pockets to do
it and Marissa
actually paid hundreds of pounds
hundreds of pounds Nate our thousand
pounds in total to actually get the
production of this video it might have
even been over a thousand
so a lot of brothers seem to think that
we're getting some sort of benefit from
this
we're not frankly we are not in a she'd
artists me and Ali and we make videos on
YouTube to try and benefit the youth so
this is not our feud but Omar came to us
and said brothers there's an issue at
hand I want you guys to help me address
it because you're very outspoken in
these things we were like you know what
it does seem like there's an issue and
we should address the inshallah so
that's why we done initiate you agree
that that's the reason we done it right
yeah so now after we done the Nasheed as
Brava Ali mentioned we had a lot of
brothers showing their concern was their
music used in than she firstly I'd like
to clarify that there was no musical
instruments used in the making of that
machine a few other issues started
coming up as well
amongst other brothers saying that
Nasheed's are impermissible you can't do
any sheeds
whether it's got music in it or not a
lot of brothers started saying that we
are imitating the Crafar and we are
doing you know a lot of wrong things and
then the she'd in the first place is
haram la dee da dee da there was a lot
of reasoning given so you know what I
know a brother personally so does Ali
who's studying in Imam Saud University
in Riyadh
he's a very close brother of mine I
speak to him nearly every single day
he's really really close out considering
one of my best friends now and I spoke
to him and he has access to some of the
key bar allama over the in Saudi Arabia
and the key bar autumn are for anyone
that doesn't know who they are
what does they owe money media yes I'm
about to clarified sorry
so the kabbalah nama i actually a select
few around 3040 ulama
that are very very big so there are
scholars that have been around in saudi
arabia for some time they've studied
extensively and they are actually picked
hand-picked to actually serve in the
council of judiciary scholars currently
i think if i'm not mistaken this 21 of
them so he has access to people like
that so I said to him bro here's the
video please find out for us is it halal
is it Haram what's wrong with it
if it was haram me and Ali and Omar with
we're fully willing to take it down and
never do any of this again
oh you know because we don't have
benefit in this so the brother done his
research and he came back to me but hold
on a second will you say he does
research now there might be people out
there saying you know what you just went
and told him how you wanted to tell him
get is about did we go and just tell him
or did he hear it so basically what I
told him to do is I told him to explain
the content yes of the nasheed to the
scholars that he asks yes asked him to
ask about the permissibility of aniseed
in the first place okay and I also asked
him to ask about the sound of dinner she
does it sound like did you hear it yes
they heard it yes this one said these
scholars had it the sort of scholars
dime about him and not that they heard
about it they heard it they heard the
nasheed it was played to them first and
they actually called other people k come
come and listen to this what do you
think of this so they actually even
asked other people's opinions who were
there now firstly I wanna put a
statement of chef in bars out there chef
in bars this is the translation he said
Islamic Nasheed's differ if these
Nasheed's are good and there is nothing
in them except calling towards goodness
and reminding people of goodness and
also to the obedience of allah azzawajal
and the messenger sallallaahu REO Selim
then there's no problem with this but if
it cools towards sins and free mixing
between men and women or it cools
towards any corruption then this is not
permissible Islamic Nasheed's
such as poetry if it's okay then it's
okay if it contains moniker then it is
Monica so basically what you have in
bars is saying is that if there is an
achiever schooling towards goodness
calling towards worshiping allah alone
calling towards worshiping allah in his
oneness then that is fine if it is
calling towards goodness it's fine if
it's calling towards bad and free mixing
then it's not good so but the question
here is does that mean doing you're
doing dowel funda she's isn't that
better
well well technically it can be classed
as dower and the reason that it is not
classed as bitter and the reason why
chef in buzz did not mention it as
bitter is because it's very very clear
that even at the time of the Prophet
sallallahu Salam's and a son bin Thabit
was a poet and the prophet sallallaahu
seldom allowed him to do this poetry
like wasallam in column Taraka trainee
watch madam in column tele denisa who
licked a colectomy Burum in cool Eamonn
Kanaka collector comma - ah you know
this is poetry describing the prophet
sallallaahu Celaeno can we see that now
of course this dower
of course if I was a non-muslim and I
heard someone doing nice poetry about
someone that's attractive what is Dow
Dawa is calling to Islam that was
calling towards allah subhanaw taala
calling towards the messenger of the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu Selim so if
he's cooling towards the prophets allah
salaam and he's saying attractive words
about him what Steckler what is that
technically so I feel like a lot of
brothers get into the issue of was it
down I wasn't not dour I feel like
that's a that's a holy define what is
down yes in the first place
what do what do you define is Dawa Geum
jandi because you have Mashhadi who says
AR rahman AR rahman you have a lot to
eat
[Music]
Rockman you come Chauncey but even
though we do know is there a different
opinion this matter though there is and
we'll get we'll go into that okay now to
further go on in Saudi Arabia in certain
masajid the Shahrukh they have their
offices in certain masajid so there's
one share who was in the Council of
judiciary scholars he is one of the key
bar or am I in Saudi Arabia is very very
big it's very very known among students
of knowledge and show you in this
country in Saudi Arabia is very big his
name is Sheikh Saud even Turkey
O'Laughlin then she'd was played to him
directly so the nasheed was played to
Sheikh Saud even Turkey Aslan as I
mentioned he's a very big scholar in
Saudi Arabia and the funny thing is
while he was actually playing it he
called the imam of the masjid he was in
he called other people come come listen
to this so they were all listening to it
and after he was played he said he he
said there's no music in this and he
also said that there's nothing wrong
with it he said in hamdullah there's
nothing wrong with this nasheed and he
gave us advice that the brothers you
know you know you need to be careful
what you do put in any she'd because you
know certain people might speak bad
about you so he was like well
hamdulillah then he/she there's nothing
wrong with it so that's she excited me
turkey Aslan
now there's another share who is in the
Council of Jeju she's Khalid Sheikh
Abdullah Rock ban it's always now he is
he as far as I know he is
mala alum he actually mentioned that
Nasheed's in general they are
permissible Nasheed's are permissible to
do and yeah that's what he mentioned
there's another shift as well who is
very very very popular chefs odd a [ __ ]
three chefs are the nasara [ __ ] three he
is in the Council of judiciary scholars
as well so he's one of the key borrow
Lama as well and he actually mentioned
that Nasheed's are permissible but
there's a few conditions to them the
conditions should be that there is no
conference shirk in them that there's no
swearing in them that the nasheed Lam
has no bid are you know there's no music
in it and that this adenosine is not
called an Islamic
she'd and the reason he said that is
because a lot of people say that if you
call something an Islamic machine then
you're inventing something new in a
slant so Robinson sisters in a nutshell
oh I don't want this to get too long
this is the opinion that we follow this
is the opinion that we feel right to
follow because we've looked into the
evidences I looked into the evidences
and for me I'm convinced that this
because the fact of the matter is we
live in an age in a society where
there's a lot of brothers subhanAllah
using music doing a lot of harm things
in their videos dancing and whatnot and
us as brothers we feel that it's right
to support people like Omer Issa who are
doing the halal option where they're not
using music they're not putting bid are
they're not putting cover and chicken
and shades and they using an alternative
for the youth to listen to now is easy
to use music what makes rather what
makes a difference is that he abstains
from that and bring the hell on
alternately we should support the
brother in what he does yes exactly
now that's our opinion that we follow
yeah the reason I'm mentioning this is
our opinion is that we have a lot of
excited brothers up there that and of
the word haram and brothers please um
pay heed to I'm about to say inshallah
you're very excited to say that things
are Haram or things are no this is Haram
and you monopolize the religion and you
say my opinion is the opinion my way and
there there is no other scholar that
says otherwise
you see we have to understand is when
you see a Hanafy brother praying with
his hands below his chest you can't go
up to him and say ah look at you you
stupid idiot you can't do that because
he's got a valid opinion behind him a
man before hanifa was our great imam so
you have to understand this in the same
way we are not like setting people that
are taking one opinion from some random
chick and Egypt sitting there in some
hot saying oh yeah pretty mixing a lot
of music is hello we're not doing that
yeah we have gone to key bar on our mob
brothers and sisters now this is the
opinion which used to follow and it's a
valid opinion it is a valid opinion now
there are there is another opinion out
there that because the Sufis do
Nasheed's you should avoid them and
certain scholars have even said that
they are haram in their opinion scholars
like Sheikh Saleh al-fulani so
he's also in the Council of judiciary
scholars now he's reasoning for it is
that the Sufis do it and he believes
that it's wrong for that reason he
believed that he believes that it's
something people should avoid and that's
his opinion brothers and sisters I
respect and love sheikh saleh al hasan
for that and and those who and i'm not
saying that he's giant allah forbid are
stuck for Allah I'm not saying that he's
someone you shouldn't ignore take
knowledge from him he knows more than me
but there's also other scholars that
said otherwise as I've provided to you
and big scholars so this is what I'm
saying this is our opinion I'm always
saying is we got just a fresh respect
you know because I'm sorry but I've been
like kind of bullied by one buffer you
know in a cyber ly cyber the cyber
attack online you know you know the
brothers just he doesn't understand this
is the issue narrow mindedness it's just
that no this how is blah blah blah blah
you know no reason no nothing just
because you have an opinion I don't have
to follow it I don't you can't come I
can't come to you and say why do things
are wrong why did you throw anything is
haha yeah silly hobby of says Allah this
is oppression it's like ignorant you
know what it's like us coming and saying
yeah shut up
yeah it's halal okay it's a lot that's
it it's a long we're not even saying
that brothers and sisters Allah tells us
in the Quran that he has made us what on
Martin wasit are the balance nation the
balance nation we are supposed to be a
balance people know people that extreme
okay know people that go extreme to one
side or the other side here suburban
sisters be balanced you have your
opinion colors we have our scholars
exactly no that's what it is and it's
sad that this in this brothers out there
but I genuinely trying to make it all
wrong like well see this color - color
mmm why was it explained properly to the
scholar this that I'm sorry it's not
fair it has been clearly explained only
clearly explained it's been plain to it
let me play Jennifer listen to it yeah
so this is some people are so extreme I
bet you after they watch this video I
will not be surprised if they come and
see all those for as a misguided I will
not be surprised because sometimes you
need to understand are you worshiping
Allah you worship in your ego
seriously just because of that I believe
what Brahma is doing is good there are
no people out there who have worked with
even as well
you know and now I don't they've gone
down there of using music you know and
it's sad no one can ask you a question
every single brother that we have asked
need or dance it off Haram Haram this is
Haram yeah do they have a struggle with
music no by the looks of it do they
struggle armies now mashallah are they
practicing brothers yes master are they
on point yes much very on point from
what we can see yeah from what we can
see yes much other guys it's not for you
I'm not surprised you're saying it's
heroically it may not benefit you but
bro this might be benefiting some sister
there man all day or some brother I'm
sorry
most of these brothers and sisters the
internet bubble yeah I'm sorry I have to
be real you're in your bubble yeah your
bubble is you are you have no understand
what's going on you have no idea what on
earth is going on so they are in their
own bubble when you're in your bubble
look in my country well they say a
person with a full stomach will never
understand the person that's hungry
that's true now this doesn't mean you
make just because all you don't
understand that you make it permissive
or no I want see hey you don't
understand how hard is in our mixing a
lot nobody's seen that we're saying you
have no idea music is the biggest
fitness out there and if there's another
alternative we will support the brothers
yeah the brothers that don't use music
we will support them and this opinion
behind it's not about community we're
gonna support it just cause few lagrimas
you know this valid reason behind it
we're just asking for you guys to
respect it and before evidence if after
this you carry on
I'm sorry but from what I can judge you
have an ego shoot know if you carry on
I'm telling you straight to your face
right now have any brother out there
whether I know you I don't need you I'm
ignoring you
yeah I'm ignoring you cuz who the hell
are you yeah I'm very sorry well forgive
me for my penis it and give me if this
is rude I don't know who are you yeah I
have six odd even Turkey else's land
I'll share top dollar rock band shakes
are the [ __ ] tree statements from she's
been buzz multiple statements and I can
see I I get messages I can see that
there's a fit now there and I can see
people benefiting from the Bravo Oh
Marissa stop
who are you to come and tell me no this
is Haram you know because if you'll is
Haram and you know some of these
brothers subhanAllah
they need to be very careful because
their brothers
whoo so hon come on and say something is
Haram they literally give a fatwa you
know what futurus a soffit what is an
Islamic ruling you make you what Allah
is made halal Haram it's like me sitting
here in front of you brothers and
sisters this is halal
I have no qualification what is all ever
to tell you this is my life that's why
I'm giving you evidence yes
these same brothers it's Haram bro it's
Haram yeah
and if these fellows came and said is
Haram we will put hands up we put our
hands up yeah but are you brother did
you do the same as you know okay they
said okay we accept favor anyways we
accept you have a reason let's not run
it out we respect your opinion respect
our opinion we will carry on doing what
we're doing you can do backflips yeah
you can do front flips do somersaults if
you like yeah we will put evidence
behind it we will carry on Superman
brother Oh Marissa and we would
inshallah be many next machine ever
featuring 50 cent there anyway guys if
you enjoyed it don't forget to subscribe
to mooses Channel and watch our Muslims
that cause the video to find out the
double extremes one extreme on the other
extreme you know we react to them check
it out I need to go goodbye
shoot shoot shoot